well it's been an absolutely packed uh
show today hasn't it we've had all sorts
of things on the program from laughing
gas to that really powerful discussion
that I'm gonna remember for an awfully
long time about
um murders of women in the domestic
environment the wig head though is going
to be just as busy with that illegal
migration legislation facing scrutiny in
House of Commons and the government's
big push on anti-social Behavior so now
we have a moment in the show we can take
a bit of a look ahead try and make sense
of it all we're joined by two former MPS
the former labor MP Heidi Alexander now
hoping to return to Parliament and the
full former conservative Minister
Alistair Burt lovely to have you both on
the program today I always think it's
quite interesting to talk to people who
are slightly removed from the day-to-day
in Westminster and you know can kind of
kick back and and talk a little bit more
freely hopefully about um some of the
issues on the table
um I don't know if there's anything in
particular that you guys are Keen to
sort of pick out but obviously the
migration Bill coming up in House of
Commons filter it's going to be a really
big one Alistair I'm interested to get
your sort of thoughts on that
um I thought the U.N HCR representative
put it very well and the issue here is
that this is a this is a problem for so
many different areas and it is a problem
because if people are forced to move
it's a problem for them and their
families and she's right that people
tend to come from conflict areas and
they go to the nearest available place
there are three and a half million in
Turkey for example we see very much the
tip of the iceberg in terms of Crossings
across the Channel having said that
it's going to continue and increase
because there is an exponential number
of people the UN itself calculates there
are 100 million refugees currently on
the Move in the world the United Kingdom
remains very attractive this isn't
something I think that can be solved by
one state alone it does have to be done
collectively how would you vote if
you're still in the comments oh I don't
know when I you know one of the joys of
not being an MP anymore
you can also admit more more honesty you
don't know the answer to everything and
you don't know what's going to work
um has there to be something that makes
it impossible for people across the
channel and take the risks that they do
and land in Ken yes I think there has
that has to be done in cooperation with
the French and that has to be done in
cooperation with others on the migration
routes when I was Minister for in in the
foreign office we worked on those routes
we spoke to people who were making the
journey to try and persuade them don't
be with the traffickers this if you've
left for a particular reason these are
the things that can help you but it is
monumentally difficult and climate
change is going to make this worse
because more people are going to be on
the move and I'm not sure the world has
really worked out how this is all going
to be dealt with it's really it's it's
true isn't it actually and that these
are huge issues that everyone is kind of
grappling with including the labor party
as well and
you can see the obvious difficulties
with what the conservatives are
proposing but I guess also when you talk
to labor more enforcement trying to
smash the gangs I mean that's difficult
to do as well isn't it yeah I mean I
think we've got the worst of all Worlds
at the moment haven't we because you
know people who are genuine Asylum
Seekers who are fleeing Civil Wars
famine
um climate change disasters they're not
being given the opportunity to rebuild a
new life it's taking ages to process
Asylum applications a big increase in
the number of Asylum applications that
are waiting to be processed under this
government
um but equally we're not removing people
who don't have genuine Asylum claims
quickly enough so yes I think we do have
to crack down on those gangs that are
smuggling people into the country and
the labor party has put forward some
proposals about using the money that the
government have set aside for the Rwanda
scheme and setting up a new unit within
the National Crime agency to work with
other European countries and europol but
we are going to have to do more to speed
up the processing of applications and
also probably reform the the sort of
safe and legal routes by which people
are coming here you don't put your
children in a boat to cross the channel
unless you're utterly desperate
um and so you know I think that yeah
that's something that we have to keep at
the back of our minds as well and when
we're talking about refugees and Asylum
Seekers I think the the fundamental
principle is that I would like our
country to treat other people as we
would like to be treated ourselves if we
found ourselves fleeing a war-torn
country it's there's one of those issues
where there is a clear division line
between conservatives and labor another
issue that we talked about on the
program where there wasn't such a clear
divide was on the Banning of laughing
gas of nitrous oxide both Lucy Powell
and Michael go very clear saying that
they wanted to ban that to make it
illegal
I just wonder it's interesting you're
talking there about you know issues that
you know you have different Shades of
Gray on which you can be a bit more open
about if you're not in politics and it
feels to me like drugs policy is is one
of them because the guys who are
supposed to look into these things at
the council for the misuse of drugs so
that actually you know what it's
probably not worth Banning laughing gas
but then from a political perspective
it's something that I guess perhaps
there's political capital and seeming
tough on what you say
if you're in a position of of making a a
decision then you've got to have an
answer yes or no and I I think one of
the problems of politics today it seems
to me is so many issues are becoming
much more polarized and it's become more
difficult for colleagues to to talk
roundly about something and also not
respond in a very knee-jerk fashion it
is someone who is getting high on
nitrous oxide is is that a good thing
the short answer is no of course it's
not so should it be stopped yes but how
would you do it and that is much more
complex in a society where people have
addictions to all sorts of things I've
just I I had a week in the states very
recently uh seeing the UN and seeing
State Department on on Middle East
issues and because cannabis has been
deregulated for example it's everywhere
and you can spell it as you walk down
main streets in Washington and New York
and things like that tourist attraction
sometimes right where people go there
specifically will that deal with the
problem by legalizing it no problem
probably won't so some of these things
are are extremely difficult I have no
particular view on nitrous oxide I've
not come across it I know that the small
canisters are used by cyclists because
they're part of the part as well right
to get your tires blown up so what's
your opposition so my reflection on all
of this listening to that debate earlier
is that you know I spend hours every
week knocking on doors in Swindon at the
moment and not one person has raised
with me the issues of nitrous oxide
um or those small little canisters that
are pretty ubiquitous across a lot of
communities at the moment what people
have raised with me on the doorstep is
rising levels of knife crime in a time
like Swindon where you know I think a
lot of people would think that someone
like Swindon is a a safe place to live
um and actually I was really surprised
having been a member of parliament in
southeast London which had a big problem
with serious youth violence and knife
crime to find similar things things
playing out on the streets in Swindon
um and so if you were asking me about
what the priority of people would be for
Action from this government
um I wouldn't have necessarily said it
was that I think you're getting back to
proper neighborhood policing
um getting enough police officers on the
streets and investing in prevention so
young people aren't getting drawn into
crime is something that the public
really want to see
um we're nearly out of time but I just
want to get
I mean you probably you're about to go
back into it so I'm not sure this is the
best question for you but what's the
thing you've enjoyed the most
after leaving Parliament what was the
thing that you've
enjoyed the most about weekends don't
tell this to me weekends because either
you had engagements in the diary uh and
of course you you worked through through
your weekends or if you didn't you
worried why didn't you have any
engagements and you worried in case you
were missing something and yeah
but the the ability to think more
broadly about things I do keep in touch
I think the abuse that MPS have suffered
is greater than it was my wife still
works in Parliament the abuse that women
suffer in Parliament is much greater
than it was the polarizing of politics
worries me a great deal so I don't miss
that I miss not being involved in
legislation and where things are going
um but I'm also a pro-chancellor i chair
the council at Lancaster University
business and being involved with
something different is very good yeah
and for me it's quite interesting
because I went off and worked with the
mayor of London for yeah and a half
years and so I was still very much in
political and an intense political job
even though I was politically restricted
at that time I do agree with Alistair
that um not doing advice surgeries on a
Friday evening
um when you're often there until eight
o'clock at night that was um it was nice
to have a little bit of a break from
that but I dare say that if I'm
re-elected I'll be back doing that yeah
make the most Friday nights now I still
care exactly thanks very much indeed
quite two as feature